well here we are people we got ourselves
some morbius early reactions and i hear
they're overwhelmingly positive so
excited leave a like leave a like for
more videos that's what you guys got to
do today yeah this comes from mcu the
direct i'm excited to see what the early
response is and keep this in mind these
are just other people's opinions these
are not our own my motto our sentiment
that i feel everyone should adopt is
just going with your own open mind and
form your own opinion when it's all done
regardless these are always fun to check
out i do i would check them out on my
own time all the time so i might as well
just do it with you guys on camera here
let's hop into it shall we so this
article on the mcu the direct a link in
the description box you want to go
through there they're really good source
and so yeah we're going to scroll
through this article so first one on the
agenda today is from sap ashley who's
from collider well
morbius is about as bad as you were
expecting a 2005 plot collides with
visually confusing cgi
to create a bit of a snooze fest oh i
don't like hearing snooze fast i need
some rest but don't worry they've saved
the worst for last
featuring some of the worst post-credits
scenes you've ever seen sony are off
their rocker okay i mean like hearing
that is one thing but hearing snoozefest
boring is probably the worst insult i
could give to any movie you could be
awful but entertaining so if it ends up
being boring and then that's gonna be a
no recommendation for him why the post
credit suit really usually the saving
grace is the most current scene i don't
know though sony has a lot of plans up
their sleeves and i have to imagine that
those are going to reveal themselves in
these scenes and hey if the venom scene
after spider-man was any indication or
the venom leather reconnaissance was any
indication who knows what they're
planning so scrolling through this looks
like uh wolf of geek streets a moon
knight of ren geekness is up on the list
john take it away in morbius matt smith
gloriously hams up the place and oliver
wood delivers some visual flair to the
action scenes
aside from that the bad plotting and
messy cgi confusing editing and worst
sound mix result in an absolute
incoherence but the post credits managed
to outdo it all this is honestly this is
all gonna be really this just made me
want to see it even more the last tweet
said it was boring but that's not what
i'm getting from either of these tweets
so far i'm getting remarkably bad and
that makes me excited that makes me very
excited but confusing editing and sound
mix ah it's too bad which what baffles
my mind is they've had three years to
keep redoing this movie that's why
though maybe they've just been tinkering
and tinkering and they didn't know when
to leave well enough alone that's two in
a row talking smack about the
post-credits scene though that's kind of
weird man it'll be good usually it's a
post-credits scene that's like well at
least that post-credit scene was good
let's see here we got a person named
martin meehan i think this is an actual
fan unfortunately after seeing a preview
screening these are my thoughts on
morbius yeah they had a gift if you
can't say something nice don't say
nothing at all oh that's um that's
really unfortunate i'm gonna say all the
nice things about more beers
i can't wait
all right here we are okay so next on
the list here cameron howe johnny oh
morbius is just as disjointed and boring
as you expected it to be boring clearly
that
clearly butchered in an edit by a studio
who had no clue what they wanted to do
with it not that there's a good film
trapped in there
mig credits are a joke but stick around
if you like roll in your eyes wow the
most common consensus is that the
postcard scenes are bad i don't know why
it's so shocking to me i feel like that
should be the thing that at least saves
the movie so now i'm expecting sitting
through 90 minutes of something dull and
then some remarkably what the heck
post-credit scenes basically what i'm
getting oh man worth it to stick around
that long this is good because if the
early expectations are like really lower
than if our expectations are really
lowered then we might go in actually
like even more it'll be like it's not as
bad as errol once said it's actually
quite fun nicole austin says well
morbius is unfortunately not great some
really shoddy vfx and 2000s formulate
plot and definitely not as fun as venom
other words boring really confused of
the future of the sony spider-verse
following the post-credits scenes and
the editing matt smith is clearly having
a blast though i mean we've had two so
far that have at least really credited
matt smith and i do know one individual
who actually did see the movie and the
only thing i'll say about what they said
about watching it because uh they're
really this individual is very
particular about not spoiling jack for
me which can bother me because i'm like
it's not a big deal man just tell me
okay and he's like no i don't want to
but he did say he really liked matt
smith a lot in the movie so i got three
opinions of matt smith being great and
he's my favorite doctor thus far and
then we got one last one here jj sounds
like a different take it's kino dude
here we go morbius is an
excellent horror tale jared leto manages
to give a performance that balances the
fragile humanity and the powerful
generosity within along with great
visuals and thrilling action morbius is
one hell of a time i i got paid for this
no no i don't believe people get paid
for their tweets like that but if they
do we've never got him paid so he says
no i mean it's funny because this is the
antithesis of everything i've heard no
one he's the only one to specifically
highlight jared leto first off yeah no
one's highlighted jared leto's
performance so i'm surprised by no one
talking about hey it's tyrese gibson at
least good people have highlighted matt
smith and then it seems like this is
just a few opinions right it's just a
few so you can't take this as a majority
but these are the early reactions we
have to go off of but you're hearing
about the visual effects not being great
you're hearing about the entity being
poor hearing is boring but matt smith is
good it's just baffling to hear this
this sounds like a troll tweet that
sounds like satire
we've seen it happen time and time again
venom was one that people really made it
sound like it was gonna be horrible like
the first venom movie and i ended up
having quite a good time with that film
i'm hoping that this will be kind of a
similar experience i'm really holding on
hope to hear hope hope yeah because the
venom movies have that sort of bargain
bin fun kooky quality about them that's
campy but somehow is charming and i keep
hoping that that's what this movie will
somehow have and within these opinions i
can fathom an outcome like that although
i i would be lying if i said i had the
amount of faith i did in a movie like
venom that has tom hardy at its disposal
over you know jared leto it's an uphill
battle trying to get me to be like ooh
i'm gonna have fun with him unless it's
house of gucci or something well i just
hope jared leto makes some daring
choices in this movie because the cool
thing about jared leto is he swings for
the fences what i mean by that is you're
either gonna get a great performance or
a what the [ __ ] is he doing performance
so you never know which gerald letter
you're gonna get and i think the thing
that about the trailer that concerns me
about jared leto in it it doesn't look
like either of those it looks like the
most normal guy ever
in this portrayal and i want that jared
leto who's who's making a choice and
sticking with it yeah this feels like
jared leto from 20 years ago got cast in
this where is the jared leto of today
yeah where's the house of gucci cheering
no that's what i want right make me cry
making me a vampire
i want to stick with my things into your
all right guys we're supposed to see
this on wednesday i'm sure they've
retracted their invite
no they want us these guys ain't coming
incredible we know they're going to love
it bring them in give them a private
screening
get some free money on the way in or
something but uh keep a lookout for our
instant reaction from the theater
we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]